[音楽]
ああああああ
これじゃあ肇社長ですあの遊戯をカードの多分4年5年前からずっと遊んでいるんです
けども全然飽きたとかは無いでしょや遺体が西崎邸宅で仕方ないんですけども最近
ちょっと時間がなくて出来ないなーって思ってた頃なんですけども僕ウェイ
気づいてしまいました母道
変えすぎた本当に入って見てごらんくださいこれをほんの一部にしか過ぎませんここに
なってるんだろうけどこれで100ないだから多分もう1万2万ぐらいあるんじゃない
かってくらいの友情カードを買ってしまいました
新しいいう業の[ __ ]が出るとめっちゃ買っちゃうんでそれの積み重ねでし5年
ずっとやってるとこんなゲッタマンでしまいましたまあこれも一部に過ぎないんです
けどねえ
1回カードバーって売ったんですけどもそれでも多分行きたいけど23年前に1件
バック打ったんですけどもやって3年でこれくらい貯まることが分かりました
ちょっとでねあのユギオ門余りにを過ぎて管理がちょっと僕の茶本ができなくなってき
たということで
遊戯は常にできる状態にしてあるんですけどもカードウォーズでどうしようもないんで
僕が使ってるでき以外のカード
すべて売ろうと思いますちなみに120枚のブラックマップ山ガールも抜きますテック
ブラマジある以外乳業カート全部打ってないんだルカとしか見てみようと思います前
ちょっと今回特別にですねちょっとあまりにカードの量が多すぎるねいつもカードを
買いに行ったり売ったりしている静岡寒冷なんていうお店があるんですけどもあの
ショップの方が実際に家に来て直線たカードを撮影していただきこれ
ました本当にありがとうございますいつもお世話になってるお店なんですげータンクん
ですけどもここにあるからそんなたくないと思うんですよ売るとき
売れるのはどっちかというとこういう
なんか通りこういうファイルにされててその入れるカード種類によって5冊くらいに
分かれてるんでたぶんここら辺でめっちゃ値段が稼げるのかなと思っておりますそれは
3回議員のデッキがたくさんあったり触れまだもうちょっと売ろうかなと思います
とりあえずもんねカードで家がいっぱいという感じでますで困ってるんでちょっと本当
に必要最低限の咳と敵残してあとは全部振ろうと思います
値段にそうしましょう僕の予想だと多分全然めっちゃ高かったんで
今回の高い読みで多分40万くらい行ったら嬉しいなぐらいだと思います約40万って
言えばいいのかハッピーでは査定の方にまいりましょうよろしくお願い致します
[音楽]
くっ
ヒュー do
ふもっすっ
ありがとう学会れていました
[音楽]
うーむ
うっ
[音楽]
皆さんは休憩中でございます
なんか想像以上に枚数や終えらしくてかなり時間がるっぽいんで一度休憩を取ることに
下げましたすーげーアッパプロだなぁやプロですね主はケガと
とても速い果たして何円になるのでしょうか点火カードスリーブから出すことぐらいは
できるんですけどもなんか余計なことすると逆に迷惑になりそうであんまり変な事は雪
あの上で動画編集してまーすこういう仕事はプロの方に任せたを買ったやイデアの
あんまりさ者数帯になるかを待ちましょう
me
[音楽]
hey
はいございます
あれん
いただきますから
[音楽]
東京から帰ってきたら
そこには
さっきまであった大量のカードが
亡くなっていたそう僕の全てのカードは j 1型によって売られてしまったのだ
です
押すことで東京行ってで僕は最後まで立ち会えなかったんですけどもいつも圭佑が
変わるに
結果とお金を受け取ってくれたってことですね結局動きなんだったとか同梱版
自分磨死後何枚のカードを打ったらしいですねまあ34年間ぐらい集めた分の月給でね
いやーよく見たけどよく見てるな
[音楽]
ブーブーどぅん
一番後ろに合計入ってるんで
7度
わー
すげー
ドンピシャじゃあから違いですよ by 上っ
104水挑戦で下っ端ん
ですめっちゃ凧授業かとそんなた府連のはいというわけで合計金額が41万円でござい
ましたのは予想がドンピシャすぎでちょっといやすごく号役にロットも散った
まあめちゃくちゃ高いっていうカードは何枚かあります
なんかここらへんがからのしめちゃんて es 4区が4000ニッセンとか
10守ってね手間の排出です自然中でたらコレ
ぼくちんちもてねますから悪魔さんの度下げればいるデデーンは売ってたのかこれ
高かったカードゾーイ単位いうとブーンブラックマジシャンガール森1枚といけんの
これ
ルーラーのペンチグってやつが14,000円
母そして一番高かったのが増殖する g
を煙のカードの天帝た寝具が1枚一番発生です
j 他にも結構ザラザラとなんか1000円してるカードがたくさんほらよ
レッドブラック3と思っていそうねそう悠遊カード結構でめちゃくちゃ高い母が多いん
でいろいろ重なって重なってご存知何になったのではないかなと思われます大量の
カードの魂があった部分
ここで14000円文丸羽根がゲットできます
今度はなるか
号+かあさん
day
うーん可愛いもう
うわぁ予防パンツ other うーん
やばいやばいよだーっ口たかっ
[笑い]
にょりますよまあ個人的には真面目ちゃったりしてえーっあっに流用やにょ本当に
カードが大継て管理できないんですよ
立ってなかった者ちゃまのかやばかったんですが結局年欠かさないし置いてるだけ場所
と積んでデイわけでちょっと求めて全部
塗らせていただきました一応州の鉄橋ちゃんと残してあるのでブーイング人生は遅れる
と思いますウーパー4 e げっ41万よ
1 re na i
year
def
待って待って
ああああああ
妖獣は馬前バージョン5
バーッ
バーン
なあ
me
teame
dea
car
うっはっはー